an unprecedented meeting happened this
morning between bishops and survivors of
alleged clergy sexual abuse 12 survivors
from around the world are urging the
Catholic Church to have a zero-tolerance
policy for abuse Niki batiste has been
following this story since last summer
she spoke to some of those survivors and
is in Rome where the meeting has taken
place the meeting ended moments ago and
we just spoke with a survivor on his way
out he said Pope Francis did not make an
appearance so now the question is will
the Pope implement the changes the
survivors want the survivor also told us
he's waited years for this moment and
he's still willing to give the Catholic
Church one last chance I'm not surprised
I'm aggravated this is the CEO of the
Roman Catholic Church
Sean Daugherty said the Pope should have
personally listened to survivors at this
morning's meeting we came to his house
to meet with him about his abuse of
priests and he wasn't there he delegated
Daugherty never imagined his very
personal crusade against Catholic clergy
sexual abuse would lead him to the
Vatican he traveled about 4,000 miles
from Pennsylvania to join eleven fellow
survivors in Rome there's only one
reason you're here only one to get them
to stop doing this to kids since we
first met Daugherty last August he's
fought for a statute of limitations
reform across Pennsylvania and
confronted the former priest he says
molested him I'm at peace right now I'm
completely at peace today's meeting is
the pinnacle in his fight for justice do
you feel that you're carrying the weight
of thousands of survivors on your own
they're carrying me so many people did
so much more than me I'm thrilled to be
a part of that it's known this chance
may never come again survivor Peter I
slay who alleges he was sexually abused
by a priest in Wisconsin at age 13 says
their group's message to Pope Francis is
clear it's really simple zero zero zero
if this summit ends and the Pope doesn't
implement full-on zero
tolerance than what it's going to
accelerate investigations by Justice
Department's and law enforcement around
the world
Sean Daugherty says he believes he's
more likely to win the Powerball than to
see the church make the changes he wants
the Vatican's sexual abuse summit
officially begins tomorrow for CBS this
morning
Niki batiste Rome